My wife told me that she thinks our
11 year old daughter is being bullied
emotionally by some girls at school.
As I drove into work,
I wondered if Jujitsu would give her some
tools to help her deal with emotional
stress and or bullying
that might be taking place.
I think we all know they answer that Daca
will give to this question. Absolutely.
Jujitsu will help.
11 years old is a perfect age for getting
in there and you will learn too is she
will learn to defend herself for
real and physical confrontations,
which will give her a real confrontation,
which will give her confidence
because let's face it,
emotional and verbal bullying is
absolutely backed up by a either
clear message of possible violence or a
subliminal message of possible violence.
Right? I mean a big group of girl
that's getting picked on the, the,
the underlying messages there,
the implied messages there that it's,
it could go physical if it had to and
when that gets removed because the,
the daughter knows how to
now fight and defend herself,
that starts to impact these
emotional bullies as well. So yes,
absolutely get her training.
I would throw some boxing in there too,
just because that is a
pretty empowering thing.
You pointed out something that feels good
and you know what? While we're at it,
let's get some working out going
on. Right. Get a pull up bar,
get way of the warrior kid like,
no kidding.
Absolutely get her way of the warrior
kid. Don't baby her too much. Yeah,
you gotta be careful of that because
she's your daughter and you say, oh no,
it's so horrible and these
girls are picking any, don't,
don't do that because guess what?
She's going to be dealing with this her
whole life. You're going to be good.
There's always bullies in every
environment, in the in school environment,
in the work environment,
in everywhere.
There's bullies and she's going to
have to deal with them. So don't,
don't baby her where she thinks that
you're the one that's going to save her
from it. Um, and I also think should
know that everyone gets bullied.
I got asked that when way the
warrior could came out. Someone said,
what did you get bullied?
And they think,
of course I would never get bullied
because I, I'm a big dude. Well,
guess what?
When I was nine years old,
I was a scrawny little nine year old kid
and every buddy that was 11 was bigger
than me and stronger than me.
Yeah.
And then when I was 11 everyone
that was 13 was bigger than me,
than stronger than me.
And when I was 14 everyone that was 16
was bigger than me and stronger than me.
So no matter who you are as a kid,
there's always somebody that's bigger
and stronger than you that's going to
bully you if they're a jerk.
So I think she should understand
that she's getting bullied right now.
But that's, that happens to people and
people get over it and get through it.
And I, I, I do think you have to be, when
you say that you can't leave the imprint,
you can't overwhelm or and say everyone
gets bullied and you can always get
bullied in the office or,
you know what I mean?
Like I'm not saying to overwhelm or
you think that's just like, there's a,
there's a lot. Did you ever see the movie
that professional? Which one was that?
The French guy. And He, Oh yeah,
there's a great scene in
that movie where the girl is,
there's like a crazy fight going on
between her parents and the apartment.
They're yelling at each other and
screaming and just slapping people that
domestic violence is going on and she
comes out and she's sitting in the hallway
and she's crying and the assassin guy
kind of walks up the stairs and she looks,
and he looks at her and she
looks at him and she says,
is life always like this or does
it get better when you get older?
And he looks at her and
says, always like this. Yeah.
So you've gotta be careful that that's
not the message that you're sending. Now.
There's some reality to that
statement. Like, yeah, guess what?
Life is always going to be hard.
And you do want to give your kids enough
exposure to the hard thing so that
they're not weak. Yeah. And they don't,
they don't go into panic mode when
something tough enters their world.
So that's why things like dude get to and
working out are good and exposing them
and letting them experience
some hard things.
But again, you just don't
want to overwhelm her. And
that's that. And by the way,
you might as well start training Jiujitsu
to their dad. Get Mom in there too.
Yeah. Now you've got an excuse to get
down in that. Jim, did you get to one?
And I know that you don't train Jiu Jitsu,
cause if you did you wouldn't be asking
this question. You be in getting,
getting her training,
making that happen.
So emotionally bullied.
Right. So this is interesting.
She's in the new warrior kid book,
the bully. There's a bully in there,
but he's not a bully like Kenny
Williamson who's a big strong bully.
He's a bully.
That's an emotional,
he kinda is d and every time there's
seems like there's going to be a
confrontation, he finds a way to
weasel out of it. Yeah. You know,
so he'll harass people,
but then he'll get harassed people.
He knows perfectly how
to push the buttons.
That's what the marks are dealing with.
This kid named Nathan James.
Vaguely familiar. Nathan
James Causes Problems. Yeah,
there's some layers in that
name for sure that I saw this.
This makes a lot of sense to me cause
I have a daughter four and a half,
by the way, it goes to pre
k. It's like a preschool.
Is that the Jujitsu school?
She goes, no, no bra. Anyway,
so she instructor, she
told me one day, um,
she said that her friends,
I'm not gonna say their
name doesn't matter. Um,
she said this friend told
me that she's not my friend.
She's only this other girl's friend.
That's emotional.
That's emotional bullying,
right?
That right for the four and a half
year old version of, by the way.
So it gets way worse at 11, by the
way. And then probably way worse at 15,
16. It's just my assumption.
So what I told her,
not to say this is the right answer.
It may be something to think about.
So my daughter does Jujitsu,
has done Jujitsu,
double leg choke when like it.
Well that's what you want
to say. Oh, you'd smash the,
and she's bigger too. She's bigger
than, than everyone, you know,
she's going to be the way.
No. What'd you tell her?
My daughter's trained to be it a
nice [inaudible] so I always had this
underlying thing.
No matter if someone be's mean to you,
that doesn't mean you be mean to them.
That makes you mean person.
I said me and people will
be mean to other people.
Nice people tend to not be
mean to other people. Right.
That's really pretty basic stuff.
Fundamental, but she's fine. Yeah. Um,
so you just keep reminding her. So,
um, so I, I told her, hey, look,
if she doesn't want to be your
friend then she's not your friend.
And that's okay. Does that
mean you be mean to her? No,
but at the end of the day, Sheen, I said,
are you stronger than her? And she said,
yeah. I said, are you smarter than,
than there? She said, yeah, I, if
she is or isn't. Here's the thing,
it's the self empowering thing.
Just like how you said where she
knows you're Jitsu. She's smarter,
she's stronger,
she can do more pull ups,
you can do more burpees and
stuff like that. All this stuff,
it starts to form in her
head, hopefully goal. Yeah.
Hopefully it'll form in her head that
if they don't want to be my friends,
that's okay. That's no loss to me.
Maybe if someone who is strong like me,
smart like me and whatever,
like me didn't want to me. Okay,
maybe that's something, but this isn't the
case. You know? It's kind of that idea.
The, the, the thing of just
saying, oh yeah, that's okay.
Not everyone's going to want to
be your friend. That's okay. Yeah.
And some people are gonna like you
and some people aren't gonna like you.
That's okay. You just be nice
to everyone. That's fine. Yeah.
I've got to ask that question, but when
we did the one warrior kid podcast,
a bunch of people asked,
oh my,
I feel like people don't want to
hang around with me and I was scared.
That's okay. Yeah. That's okay.
You don't need to hang around
with people all the time. I don't,
I don't like even like
hanging around with people.
I didn't say that because I don't want
to turn it over to social person like me.
But yeah,
that makes it in that thing
or I think you just said were,
cause my daughter always asks, you know,
did people not want to be your friend?
Or um, what she'd like bump her
head real hard. She be like,
did you use to bump your head
when you were little? You know,
she always wants to know like, am I
alone in this whole whole deal? And men,
it seems like you're really helps.
When I say no,
I used to do all the time I show her
like my scars and stuff like that and
she'll be like, oh, and you can tell she
feels better about it. That's pretty cool.
It's weird. I think that would help
with the bullying thing and it's good.
Your daughter's smart and so she has the
capability of formulating that question.
I bet a lot of kids might
not be able to even say, hey,
did you bump your head too?
Whereas a parent,
if you did recognize that they probably
feel alone. And so if you say, Oh,
I know you bumped your head. I used
to bump my head too one time. Look,
I got a scar on my head.
It happened to me too.
So they don't make your kids
beg for a partner in the world.
Give it to him. Yeah. Follow the
Echo Charles model of parenting.
And that makes sense too
now that I'm thinking of,
because like even as an adult,
okay, so you got a kid and they're
like, hey, did you, I don't know,
did you bump your head like this and
get blood on your head and whatever when
you're little and you're like, you're
like, yeah, and if you add this,
and this is how I dealt with it,
right?
Because a lot of times like you give
him a little path. Yes, exactly. Right.
So you got, you know, you've
got this poor little kid.
The bumped her head and it's like, Dang,
I don't even, I've never felt this before.
There's a lot of paint. There's
blood. Whoa, that's scary.
I don't know really how to deal with it.
Right?
So of course you go to your dad and
then your dad's like, yeah, Hey, yeah,
I've done it. This is how I did it. This
is how I dealt with it. And she's like,
okay, maybe I can deal with it. And even
adult, because adults, we do that too.
You know, like, Dang, I'm
getting, I don't know,
audited getting audited who
first time, whatever, Jocko, hey,
you know, or you know, your friend
or whatever. I was like, hey,
I got audited and this way he cares back.
This is like how you deal with
it and all this stuff. Boom.
You feel better about it indeed. And more
empowered. And that's on top of that.
You did too. If I got audited out where
you're at and know what you do to that.
Not by the way,
chuck.